comme des rivaux et des compétiteurs.
Donc Israël, qui dans les années 1980
faisait pression sur les US et améliorait leurs relations avec l'Iran
craignait maintenant le rapprochement États-Unis-Iran,
et pensait que cela retomberait
sur la dépense d'Israël pour la sécurité.
A la place, Israël a cherché à pousser l'Iran
dans un isolement grandissant.
Ironiquement, ça arrivait à un moment
où l'Iran était plus interéssé
par faire la paix avec Washington
que par la vue de la destruction d'Israël.
L'Iran s'est lui-même isolé,
par son radicalisme
et après avoir indirectement aidé les Etats-unis
dans la guerre contre l'Irak en 1991,
les iraniens espéraient
qu'ils seraient récompensés en étant inclus
dans l'architecture sécuritaire d'après guerre de la région.
Mais Washington a décidé d'ignorer les espoirs iraniens,
comme ils le feront dix ans plus tard en Afghanistan,
au lieu de ça, ont participé à intensifier l'isolement de l'Iran,
et c'est à ce moment, entre 1993 et 94,
que l'Iran a commencé à transformer
son idéologie anti-israélienne
en une politique d'action.
Les iraniens pensaient que quoi qu'ils fassent,
même s'ils modéraient leurs opérations
les Etats-Unis continueraient à chercher à les isoler,
et la seule manière dont l'Iran pouvait forcer Washington
à changer sa position, était d'imposer un prix
aux Etats-Unis s'ils ne changeaient pas cette position.
Le but le plus facilement atteignable était un processus de paix
et à présent la proclamation idéologique iranienne
était d'être au coeur d'un problème non conventionnel
et l'Iran a commencé à supporter de manière intensive
les groupes palestiniens islamistes qu'il avait auparavant
soigneusement évité.
En un sens, ça paraît paradoxal,
mais selon Martin Indyk
de l'administration Clinton,
les iraniens n'avaient pas entièrement eu tort
car plus il y aurait de paix
entre Israël et Palestine,
selon les américains, plus l'Iran serait isolé.
Plus l'Iran est isolé, plus il y aurait de paix.
Donc pour Indyk, et ce sont ses propres mots,
les iraniens avaient un intérêt à nous tromper
dans le processus de paix
pour contrer notre politique d'endiguement.
Pour contrer notre politique d'endiguement,
rien a voir avec l'idéologie.
Mais même à travers les pires moments d'imbroglio,
chaque parti a tendu la main à l'autre.
Netanyahu, après son élection en 1996,
a tendu la main aux iraniens pour voir
si il y avait un quelconque moyen
de ressusciter la doctrine de périphérie.
Téhéran n'était pas intéressé.
Quelques années plus tard, les iraniens ont envoyé
une proposition compréhensive de négociation au gouvernement Bush,
une proposition qui montrait qu'il y avait une possibilité
d'entente entre Iran et Israël, à nouveau.
L'administration Bush n'a même pas répondu.
Les protagonistes n'ont jamais manqué une opportunité
de manquer une opportunité.
Mais ce n'est pas un conflit ancien.
Ce n'est même pas un conflit idéologique.
Les hauts et les bas d'hostilité
n'ont pas changé par zèle idéologique
mais plutôt avec les changements de paysage géopolitique.
Quand les impératifs sécuritaires d'Iran et Israël
ont ordonné la collaboration, ils l'ont fait
malgré une opposition idéologique létale de chacun.
Quand les impulsions idéologiques de l'Iran se sont téléscopées
avec ses intérêts stratégiques,
les intérêts stratégiques ont toujours prévalu.
C'est une bonne nouvelle car cela signifie
qu'aucune guerre ou opposition
n'est une conclusion courue d'avance.
Mais certains veulent la guerre.
Certains pensent ou disent que nous sommes en 1938,
que l'Iran est l'Allemagne,
et Ahmadinejad est Hitler.
Si on accepte ça comme vrai,
nous sommes en effet en 1938, l'Iran est l'Allemagne,
Ahmadinejad est Hitler
et la question que nous devons alors nous poser est :
qui souhaite jouer le rôle de Neville Chamberlain ?
Qui risquera la paix ?
C'est une analogie délibérément voulue,
pour éliminer la diplomatie
et quand on élimine la diplomatie,
on rend la guerre inévitable.
Dans une conflit idéologique, il ne peut pas y avoir de trève,
pas de match nul, pas de compromis,
seulement la victoire ou la défaite.
Mais plutôt que de rendre la guerre inévitable
en considérant tout ça comme idéologique,
il serait sage de chercher des moyens
de rendre possible la paix.
Le conflit entre Iran et Israël est un nouveau phénomène,
vieux de quelques décennies seulement
dans une histoire de 2500 ans
et précisément parce que ses origines sont géopolitiques,
ça signifie que des solutions peuvent être trouvées,
des compromis peuvent être arrangés,
peu importe la difficulté que cela peut représenter.
Après tout, Yitzhak Rabin lui-même disait :
« On ne fait pas la paix avec ses amis.
On fait la paix avec ses ennemis. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)